painful reminders of cambodia's genocide
during the late 1970s are not hard to
find in the country's capital here in
Phnom Penh one of the most heinous
crimes perpetrated by the Khmer Rouge
regime is on display an entire Secondary
School building was transformed into a
prison hospital beds into torturing and
killing tools some of its victims were
party members whose loyalty was doubted
most Lego victims were put into this and
it chained to demand while the Camaros
interrogator would be here to to
interrogate people and to to hurt people
to torture people the victims by using
electrical shock taking off nails
classrooms were turned into cells in
tall slang prison the memory and Justice
Center estimates more than 18 thousand
people were killed over the period of
four years many of them appearing in
these photographs are still documented
as missing genocide operations were not
limited within Prison Walls it targeted
most other segments of the country's
social fabric as per surviving documents
Millions have been compiled over more
than 30 years to record the tragedy and
prevent it from happening again
imagine that all the high school in
Cambodia from grades 7 to 12 read this
one
then you have about 2 million young
people who
came to a specific understanding that
this
cannot should not be repeated
this Survivor Sam ready suffered until
the Khmer Rouge regime came to an end
but the pain of the torture remains with
him he still recounts what happened even
guiding visitors to one of the most
notorious Mass Killing Fields near Phnom
Penh for more than 350 Mass Graves were
found
the genocidal policies of the Khmer
Rouge ultimately resulted in the deaths
of more than one million people
Freddie acar Al Jazeera